we have a voicemail number that if you
have a message for me you can call that
number is
2192 David P here is an interesting
voicemail from a republican who says
they are they are a republican I didn't
convert them out of being Republicans
but they have changed their mind about
at least some issues and they like the
show interesting message from a
Republican hey how you doing David uh
this is John from Massachusetts uh I
just want to say uh I'm actually a
registered Republican but I I do enjoy
your show uh you're definitely
I actually started listening to it uh
driving home from work beautiful you
know I was like wow this guy's you know
talking out of his ass I mean part of my
language but that's the reaction from
even people that like the show so no no
concerns there sir you know I
you definitely grew on me and you
definitely changed my mind about
something there you go uh and I'd be
curious what things those are by the way
I really do enjoy uh when you're making
fun of Donald Trump uh that that's very
funny just gotta say you should keep
that up you do it pretty good you I
probably I should come on yourself as a
guest soul and impersonating
in everyone's saying it would just be so
great so thank you so much David and
have a wonderful day all right the Trump
impression is so-so I don't know that
that's the uh best moment of the
voicemail but listen we have a ton of
right Wingers in the audience who I
never hear from who don't insult me who
don't say anti-semitic things who uh
don't make threats who just listen to
get a different opinion and sometimes we
find points of agreement and that's a
really great thing I welcome that I
think that that's fantastic if I'm only
speaking to left Wingers
what the hell am I doing at the end of
the day so A beautiful voicemail great
to hear from you we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today Oklahoma voters
have rejected legalizing recreational
Cannabis what is this the first such
failure we will discuss the White House
has endorsed a new Senate Tick Tock Bill
and is urging Congress to pass it
quickly does that make sense should
Tick-Tock be banned or should it be
regulated or should it be controlled or
whatever the case may be we will discuss
and lastly New York city mayor Eric
Adams is now telling stores to have
customers remove their masks when they
come in in order to try to cut down on
shoplifting and thefts and burglary and
robbery or whatever the term is that is
appropriate uh stick ups I guess is what
we're calling them I don't know you all
understand what I'm saying remove the
mask Eric Adam says so that they would
be identified on your security cameras
and maybe be less likely to do it
interesting all of those stories and
more when I am joined by producer pat on
the bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount and save big off of the cost of
a membership I welcome you all to the
bonus show if you are not a member we
will be back with a new show tomorrow
but why wait we can be together again in
just a few minutes on the bonus show